Hogwarts Legacy is shaping up to be the
game long time Harry Potter fans have
been waiting years for and we're now
officially less than 100 days away from
having the title in our hands so whether
you need a refresher on the confirmed
details or if you're looking for news on
the game for the first time once at the
ready because here are 50 Hogwarts
Legacy facts we know for sure all right
number one Hogwarts Legacy was
officially announced with a trailer at
the PS5 Showcase Event back in September
of 2020 and the game was originally
slated for a 2021 release but in January
of 2021 the game was delayed and given a
new much broader release window of 2022.
fast forward to August of 2022 Avalanche
announced a new release date of Friday
February 10 2023. Hogwarts Legacy is set
to release on PS4 PS5 Xbox One Xbox
series s and X as well as Steam and the
epic game store and hey consider using
Creator code rack and tour to support
the channel if you do pre-order from
epic now if you pre are the deluxe or
collectors edition of the game you'll
get 72 hours of Early Access which means
you'll get to play on Tuesday February
7th if you pre-order the digital Deluxe
on either the Xbox One or PS4 you'll
also receive the next-gen version as
well so two copies for the price of one
this is the standard box art for the
game while the deluxe edition shows a
much darker side of the Wizarding World
there's also a subtle difference between
the Xbox and Playstation versions of the
deluxe cover with the Microsoft version
having a dragon pictured in the top left
corner yet it's seemingly absent from
the PlayStation versions the game is
still slated to land on the Nintendo
switch as well however at the time of
this recording there's no confirmed
release date other than to say it will
not be launching alongside the others
now a full trailer of this game actually
leaked all the way back in 2018 when a
Reddit user named Vape This bro posted
it online apparently he was part of a
mall survey group that was shown a
trailer for the game and he somehow
managed to get by without signing an NDA
at this point though they've officially
released a total of 12 trailers for the
game which includes the official reveal
trailer a PlayStation state of play
gameplay reveal trailer a behind the
scenes Dev interview trailer Sebastian's
Dark Legacy Trailer A PS5 next-gen
immersion trailer two ASMR videos four
common room tours and the haunted
hogsmeade shop Quest trailer now if
you're wondering about the devs for this
game it's Avalanche software and no it's
not the devs who worked on Just Cause
this is a different studio now speaking
of all the official footage that's been
shared about the game they also showed
an additional cut scene as well as
behind the scenes Dev footage at an
Autodesk presentation now this Autodesk
presentation can actually be viewed in
full on the official Autodesk YouTube
channel the game is not an MMO and it is
being developed as an open world action
RPG and also will not have multiplayer
all this according to the game's
official FAQ WB is publishing the game
under the portkey games label which is a
label specifically created for the
Wizarding World of Harry Potter Hogwarts
Legacy will release here in the US with
a T for teen rating from the ESRB for
Fantasy violence blood mild language and
use of alcohol we also know they're
using the Unreal Engine for the project
the PC version will support nvidia's DL
ss3 technology which according to Nvidia
boosts performance for all GeForce RTX
gpus by using AI to Output higher
resolution frames from a lower
resolution input now as for the story of
Hogwarts Legacy thanks to a quick screen
capture of the daily profit in this
Hogwarts Legacy trailer we expect the
game will take place in 1890 putting
this well before Harry Ron and
Hermione's time at Hogwarts and actually
even a bit before Dumbledore's time at
Hogwarts that being said devs have
confirmed a few familiar faces from the
original series such as peeves
Gryffindor House ghosts nearly headless
Nick and while the other house ghosts
haven't been explicitly confirmed yet we
do see the fat fryer here and I expect
the Bloody Baron and the gray lady will
make an appearance as well oh and we
can't forget Professor pin's teaching
History of Magic here now much to the
dismay of many fans quidditch will not
be playable in Hogwarts Legacy however
broom flight 4 traversal and broom race
challenges are part of the game players
can also fly brooms to explore locations
around the castle and speaking of Flight
Around the castle hippogriffs and
thestrals have also been confirmed as
Mount options although the thestral is
only available as a bonus for the deluxe
or collector's edition of the game and
as for that deluxe edition it will also
include access to the dark arts battle
arena and the dark arts cosmetic set the
digital version of the deluxe also
includes a dark arts Garrison hat yes
there is a slight difference between the
digital Deluxe and the physical Deluxe
the collector's edition of the game will
include all of the same benefits as the
digital Deluxe Edition in addition to a
steelbook an in-game Kelpie robe and a
life-size floating wand with a book base
in August Community manager Chandler
wood unboxed the Collector's Edition on
the official YouTube channel and it was
met with a pretty strong sense of
disappointment from fans Not only for
the 299 price tag but also for the
lackluster items included PlayStation
has been heavily involved with the
marketing for Hogwarts Legacy and
they've now confirmed a number of timed
exclusive pieces of content both PS4 and
PS5 players will have one year of
exclusive access to the haunted
hogsmeade shop quest which grants access
to an additional dungeon the shopkeepers
Cosmetic set and an in-game hogsmeade
shop which is called stitches and drafts
there's also the Felix felicis potion
recipe which is yet another pre-order
bonus but this one is only available to
PlayStation players you can also use the
liquid luck potion to reveal gear chests
on the minimap for one in-game day and
speaking of gear chests we've also
gotten confirmation that some chests
conceal their rewards differently than
others we got a brief look on the
official social media Accounts at a
disillusionment chest which has a large
eye in the center scanning back and
forth for nearby Wizards seems likely to
say a disillusionment charm should do
the trick to open this one Avalanche and
WB also confirmed fans will be able to
link their Wizarding World Fan Club
accounts to their WB accounts by Lane
linking this account you will unlock a
beat skull mask an exclusive house
fanatic robes players who link their
accounts will also have the option to
bring over their house and one type from
The Wizarding World site and I know what
you're thinking what about the Patronus
well at this time of recording no
official word on the Patronus coming
over there have been two official
companion books confirmed the first
being the Arden making of Hogwarts
Legacy which will be published by inside
editions this 252-page book will include
original concept art exclusive
interviews as well as behind the scenes
facts and information about the game
making process it's set to release the
same day as the game on February 10th
the other companion book is Hogwarts
Legacy the official game guide which is
being published by Scholastic this one
won't be released until a month after
the game as Community manager Chandler
Woods said they want people to
experience and discover things for
themselves before having the guide which
I could certainly appreciate now
throughout the game we're going to have
NPC companions to Aid and fight
alongside us in our journey three of
them have been confirmed so far
Sebastian sallow a charming and
extroverted Slytherin Nats ionai a wise
and quick-witted Gryffindor and Poppy
Sweden a bright and compassionate
Hufflepuff Sebastian's storyline will
center around his twin sister who
suffers from a debilitating curse as for
nad's side she transferred to Hogwarts
from wagadu the largest Wizarding School
in the world she transferred to Hogwarts
when her mother became the Divination
professor as for poppy she has a close
bond to magical creatures and believes
they have far more redeeming qualities
than humans she also has a particularly
strong aversion to poachers and those
who work with him at some point in the
game we'll receive this book which
Avalanche is referring to as the
Hogwarts Field Guide we get a brief look
at the book in game during this scene
here and I think it's pretty safe to say
this is going to be our Quest log of
sorts the room of requirement will not
only make an appearance in Hogwarts
Legacy but it will actually play a vital
role in our character's Journey at
Hogwarts it's here we'll be able to sew
and harvest plants brew potions and
upgrade gear not only that will also
unlock vivariums where we can nurture
our own menagerie of magical beasts this
space can be freely customized to match
your own personality and magical
Specialties magical creatures will be
featured prominently with several of the
most popular Wizarding World creatures
like centaurs goblins grab horns trolls
hippogriffs even dragons and plenty more
have been officially confirmed some
creatures that we encounter have been
corrupted by a mysterious dark magic
While others are threatened by poachers
players can actually rescue some of
these creatures and nurse them back to
health in the room of requirement as for
the more nefarious creatures in Fury
have been seen on multiple occasions and
if you know the lore of the inferior you
know that also means there has to be a
dark Wizard or witch behind it all as
for the mentors they were seen briefly
in the first trailer but we haven't seen
them in any of the other trailers they
are on the official box art for the
deluxe version of the game though so it
seems a safe bet they will make an
appearance at some point in Hogwarts
Legacy as well another key plot point
from the story is that our main
character receives a late acceptance
letter to Hogwarts and will be on a
journey uncover a hidden truth of the
Wizarding World Avalanche has also
teased some sort of pivotal event that
our character survives before starting
out at Hogwarts we'll also begin our
schooling as a fifth year which is
certainly unusual for a new student the
true reason for this late start has yet
to be revealed but it's likely related
to our main character's special ability
which is a power to perceive and master
ancient magic JK Rowling is not directly
involved in the project and this is not
a new Wizarding World story from her
however Avalanche has collaborated
closely with her team on all aspects of
the game to ensure it remains in line
with the magical experiences fans expect
the primary conflict of the game appears
to center around our main character and
the ancient magic they possess there's
also rumors of a rebellion being led by
the goblin ranrock whom we see having a
particularly intense confrontation with
the player and Professor fig during the
state of Play trailer van rock appears
to be working with a dark wizard by the
name of Rookwood a surname fans of the
Potter series will no doubt recognize we
also have official comp information that
this is Professor Abraham Ronan and also
that he's head of Slytherin house this
is Professor heckett our defense against
the dark arts teacher and Avalanche has
also confirmed we'll meet up with a
Weasley or two and it seems highly
likely the witch here is Professor
Weasley we can assume that thanks to
some text labels that were spotted in
that Autodesk presentation that I
mentioned earlier our potions Master is
a former Aura by the name of Professor
sharp and will definitely be able to
sneak around the castle at night given
this tease from the official Twitter
account player choice will certainly
play a key role in the game however it
appears Avalanche has stopped short of
creating a full-blown morality system
the official FAQ does confirm players
will encounter various quests and
storylines that will influence the witch
or wizard they choose to become as for
what those choices will entail three of
the big ones are likely to involve the
unforgivable curses as all three have
been confirmed for Hogwarts Legacy
that's right imperio crucio and Avada
Kedavra will all be usable by the player
in some form in Hogwarts Legacy Avada
was confirmed in the state of Play
trailer while crucio was shown during
Sebastian's Dark Legacy trailer and then
imperio was confirmed in a social media
post on Halloween but how exactly will
these curses and dark magic play out in
the game I have some big ideas about
just how evil you can be in Hogwarts
Legacy and I put all those thoughts into
the video on the right side of your
screen now so definitely check that one
out next as always thank you all so much
for watching I'll talk to you again soon